[Music]
all right here we are back once again
it's monday yeah and pook's trying to
jump up on top of the laptop
yeah she's here she comes again
that was like the fourth time yeah he
was like we can't put her down on the
floor put it over you need to accept it
i said no she's like stop talking to the
lights
i imagine humans just seem insane from a
cat's point of view oh i'm sure they did
all they do is sit in this room talk to
lights
yeah it's like what are they even doing
they're not petting me they're not
feeding me
nothing is pooky involved yeah i never
wanted to do anything
[Laughter]
yeah they never want to catch lizards
[Laughter]
humans are so stupid yeah i bring them a
lizard every couple days and they
they let it go i don't understand it
yeah poor pokey she doesn't understand
the people
yeah mommy and daddy are crazy they're
like we don't those humans don't
understand the value of nutrition
okay yeah but hopefully she won't like
jump i'm just i don't mind if she's on
the desk i just don't want her jumping
on the
keyboard because she really likes to sit
on the keyboard we just recorded the
review for
uh what was that vampire lovers
if you guys want to jump on that that's
on shutter go ahead and watch that
tonight you'll be able to see the review
tomorrow
no is it when is it it's not tomorrow
friday it goes up friday or for patrons
it goes up on thursday
morning like you know what i mean she
runs the schedule around she's wearing
the pants around here
i thought it went up yeah tom doesn't
have any idea what's going on ever
i was sitting there playing [ __ ] star
wars [ __ ]
what's it called squadrons squadrons and
uh pookie kept [ __ ] with me and i'm
ignoring her and i'm trying to fly the
damn time reaper and [ __ ]
she goes [ __ ] this and she jumps up on
top in front of the television and
starts smacking the television
she was smacking all those smacking
spaceships yeah smacking his face ships
like daddy's not [ __ ] dancing she's
nuts man you were crazy
and i came in here and she started
attacking the laptop yeah
yeah well like i said she doesn't like
when you're not when you're paying
attention to something else
so we're going to talk about this
italian flick we saw last night yeah
this is actually one that was just added
to
netflix a couple of days ago and uh it's
called
the binding or illigame if you would
it's a pretty fur it's a pretty good
flag it's not it's not like an
old-fashioned traditional italian movie
it's like a modern movie
just like well it's well in a way it's
not like i guess what you saying like
it's not like an old-fashioned like a
jello movie
this is like a gothic horror i mean
pretty much the way that it's
shot um was very reminiscent at least to
me of like haunting a hill house uh that
kind of stuff like a very
muted color palette um just like stuff
kind of creeping around in the
background that you couldn't quite see
like in the shadows and stuff hints of
the exorcist
yeah it had some possession stuff but i
feel like it was more
i guess it was kind of possession but it
was kind of like witchcrafty
culti type of thing going on i mean
basically
so what the story is i think the person
that directed it the guy that directed
it dominico
emmanuelle de feudus i guess is how you
pronounce the last name
um this might be his first movie i'm not
entirely sure
but basically what the story is um it
takes place in southern italy somewhere
and there's a couple who
the guy's name is francesco and i think
the
the wife's name is emma i think now
they're not married yet but i guess
they're going to get married or they're
going to get engaged or something like
that now she has a daughter named sophia
who looks like she's about
i don't know maybe 10 ish she's going to
do it again
i know she's thinking about it growled
when i grabbed her she's like
you're frustrating me there she goes
she's going to go up on that side she
can go on that side because
because that laptop is she wants to run
across the keyboard yeah she really
wants to browse she's like it's nice and
warm and it's got squishy buttons and
lights and stuff go ahead go
go you can go up on that side you can go
on that side fold you can go up on that
side now she's confused because i was
because i was kicking her off i touched
her i touched her back and she was like
she makes that [ __ ] noise
but yeah so uh so the setup is that this
couple who are not married
but are going to you know are planning
to get married at some point in the
future
um the daughter sophia is i guess
emma's daughter but not his daughter so
i guess she's from like uh yeah she made
it there she just
made the jump she's from like the
hyperspace yeah
yeah she's gonna back their fart around
um so
yeah so this little family unit is going
to this kind of remote
uh manor house in southern italy uh
to meet francesco's mother
now francesco's mother is a very
old-fashioned
woman like the whole like you guys are
not married so you have to sleep in
separate rooms type of person
um and she's also seems to be
into witchcraft maybe possibly in a cult
in in a cult we're not really sure
there's like all these kind of like
people
hanging around and she's like always
kind of whispering to him and no one you
know and
emma is like creeping around going like
who the [ __ ] are all these people what
is going on it seems like really
sinister
and as time goes on there's like all
this there's actually a really great
shot like early on like with all these
trees like out in this orchard or like
this
field or whatever and like all of them
are like up and like
all of them are like upended like all
the roots out and everything
and they don't even really explain like
why exactly that that's
why that is hey nope oh my goodness
knocking alice cooper off what are you
doing you can't do that to alice cooper
you've lost your mind that's it
oh you being bad poke look at her back
there look at her little butt stars
lambie and [ __ ] alice cooper uh
they're getting beat up by a cat
getting beat up by a cat we have to
rearrange
we have to rearrange all the leads yeah
sophie says uh puke has a lot to say
today she does oh man she's nuts why are
you being crazy
she's yeah she's she feels really uh
insecure today i guess and she's kind of
like trying to get everybody's attention
i'm not really sure
she doesn't need to go outside and play
she does this a little bit sometimes but
today she seems like really
very spiritual yeah she's really all up
in our [ __ ] today yeah
but she's not usually jumping back up
there what's the problem
[ __ ] okay it's like having a little tiny
little child
cross between a child and a bear
and a kitty you know that no one listens
to you when pookie is there that's what
i figured i mean because
like i can't really concentrate on what
i'm saying with her like she's jumping
around and being like a monkey but
knocking [ __ ] off of her growling
growling
[Laughter]
our kitty's insane that's how she says
no yeah
that's how she says a lot of things but
yeah that's that's her little frustrated
noise like
yeah she goes like that but yeah so
so that's the setup of this movie is
that to go to this like creepy old house
with this creepy old
like lady and then weird [ __ ] starts to
happen with a little girl where it
almost kind of seems like
you're not really sure if the mom like
uh if francesco's mom is like trying to
do something like they're gonna
sacrifice this little girl
or if there's something else going on so
that was like kind of well done
now like i said if you like um gothic
horror you'd probably be into this
it's not real uh fast-paced it's not
real action-packed
um it's not even really that scary
there's like kind of some cool imagery
like i like what they did like with the
eyes i like what they did with like one
of the spirit things
or what i guess she's not really a
spirit maybe
but um kind of like possessed-y people
at the end and i thought that looked
kind of cool
um overall this was just like okay
this is kind of like a middle of the
road um it's well shot the acting's
really good especially like the little
girl that's in it because child actors
are kind of hit and miss but she was
actually
quite good in this and you know some of
the like scenes are creepy
i thought the story was a little
convoluted
like i'm not entirely sure like i liked
the ambiguity about you weren't really
sure
who the villain was or what exactly was
going on like
until the end but even at the end i'm
not entirely sure i knew
exactly what was going on you know what
i'm saying
like i kind of got the gist but i'd
probably have to watch it again like
to sort of like figure out what the hell
exactly the story was and why
it kind of went the way it went yeah but
like i said if you like
you know foreign if you liked haunting
of hill house if you like you know
gothic horror
stuff that's not like super super scary
or anything but it's kind of
you know just creepy atmospheric that
kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
then uh you might like this one like i
said it's on netflix
it seems like they're i mean i do like
that they're trying to um
you know add a lot of like foreign
horror movies and stuff knocked a damn
chair door
i thought i heard something [ __ ] fall
you made the camera go all blurry uh
yeah well you know that's all right
but yeah so like i said i can't say like
a huge amount i don't want to spoil
anything because it does like kind of
have interesting like
twists and stuff it's a competent movie
uh but
it to me it didn't really stand out as
anything special it's just
i didn't see it i'm not going to say it
was a waste of time watching it but just
kind of forgettable yeah that's kind of
where i was at it was like
it was like it's it's a decent movie
it's a decent watch like it's
entertaining you actually do want to
like watch until the end to see what
happens but it's not like a real
forgettable or like i would take that
other one vampire lovers over this any
day that 1970
camera film lesbian vampires just
boobalicious well that one had all the
boobs don't don't ruin it because it's
like where
you know i'm just no i'm just saying
that like people don't get to watch our
review of it until like thursday or
friday
it's like a porno movie gonna happen
it doesn't really happen but you know
it's classy too classy
it's too classy this [ __ ] is dirty you
know
a lot of nudity yeah yeah you see that
one
i'd rather see that one i yeah i feel
you like i said i
like italian horror i like gothic horror
this one is a perfectly serviceable
gothic horror story but the british give
you boobs
true i don't think there was any boobs
in here and everybody's cute
everybody's cute in those little british
movies yeah
if you weren't cute you weren't going to
be in a movie just you know
yeah even boob system boob twins
what's it called was that twins of evil
twins of evil yeah all four of them
yeah that was a good one so uh yeah
today is monday and
actually uh our club night memento mori
is finally restarting this evening so i
guess we'll be going to that see how
that goes i haven't been to the club in
a while
that's true well because it's i'm closed
your body is ready
yeah yeah it'll it'll be fun i've been a
long time it'd be nice to see everybody
probably take it oh man nap before i go
i would like to but i doubt i'm gonna be
able to i'd have a hard time sleeping
during the day
yeah man at least we'll do a little tour
we'll see how everybody's
doing you know have a drink or two and
if [ __ ]
if i get tired and we'll just [ __ ]
come home one hour or so early
i have to be out till three i think
tonight too there it's a crossover with
uh memento mori and uh disco somber
disco sombre whatever whatever that is
no that's that oh yeah yeah yeah
that's uh that's right disco knight
just go with a k yeah it's just kind of
like the that kind of like dark wave in
like dark indie time gotta be good so i
think that'll be kind of cool so i think
those djs are gonna switch out yeah
so i think that'll be kind of cool but
yeah so maybe we'll take some video or
something
yeah we'll see if we remember right like
well if you take your um
a tablet yeah take your tablet i don't
have anything to carry the tablet in
it's the size of that [ __ ] thing
i know it's too big it's just too big to
go in my purse
yeah i mean i could take a big giant
purse but that would be the only way
you want me to we'll see if i can take a
few weeks i can i can dig up a bigger
place
i mean you know let's do that it's not
like i have to i can
just put it in a little backpack that'll
go with your outfit do you have a little
backpack
a cute backpack you gotta get your cute
backpack i used to have one but the i
think the bottom tore out of it okay
get you when it's like a little bat or
something well that's what my that's
what my
leather purse looks like yeah but it's
just like regular purse size
and i and um the your tablet is a little
bit too big to fit in there
and at least you don't take like your
vape with you anymore because i used to
take up like
a third of my putters i don't have to
anymore i have to take it yeah don't
even have the urge to smoke
yeah tell me about vaping got me quit it
did you quit
almost immediately like it's like i
think it was immediately like as soon as
you started
yeah day i got a [ __ ] started vaping
it was the day i quit
yeah and that's been and then i quit
vaping
yeah well it's like um you kind of like
vaping is good like to kind of
transition you out of it but after a
while it's almost kind of like you just
stopped thinking about it
yeah you know i could i i still have
everything i vaped like
uh [ __ ] couple months back i took a
big hit off of it and i was like
because there's no nicotine in it i had
it down to zero nicotine yeah we started
like going whatever and i just started
to take a big hit out of it and i was
like what did i see in this
yeah you know i mean there's just didn't
eat it
yeah mangoes mango said he met the twins
from twins of evil
they were cute he said he had a drink
with him too yeah they were cute
they're like they look like they're
about what 18 when they did that movie
playboy bunnies but or something like
something like that but
yeah they were cute you had to run
around [ __ ] in those bustiers
drowning in their own boobs
and surrounded in your own boobs british
british the british people knew how to
[ __ ] that's how that guy is to come
see the movie that's how tom wants to
die
being drowned in a sea of blood
i don't want to die at all well i hate
today i hate to be the one to break into
you but
i can think of worse ways to go all
right so uh yeah
that's probably all we got to say about
you know like i said if you're into like
gothic horror and you got like an hour
and a half to kill then [ __ ]
go over there and watch the binding on
there don't i
i imagine there's a dubbed version but
like i said i never recommend dubbing
i watch the the whatever closed
captioned
version because i can't we're stubbed i
can't stand dubbing
it drives me crazy but it does seem like
every movie that they put on netflix
they do have a dubbed version which is
nice that they give you the option
but because some people like i don't
want to read subtitles book did
it's like if i wanted to read i'd read a
book instead of watching a movie
but you know what i mean like i said i
don't like typing so anyway um
we will be back tomorrow and uh since
we're going out tonight we probably will
not have time to watch a movie so
tomorrow will probably be a sidetracks
so we can talk about what we did at the
bar if anything exciting happens
yeah because we haven't seen everybody
in so long yeah
but yeah so uh we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow and thanks for helping
bye
bye